bien alors johnny comme maintenant tes
patrons de boîtes de nuit on va faire
une interview brefs délais
bon
alors c'est à base de questionnaires de
pousser comme dans les bois
johnny hallyday
there
vite chez les jeunes
orange a tapé dans l'oeil
chérie
encore
pour quelle faute hein tu le plus
d'indulgence la faiblesse
qu'elle est
magisto récemment mis
en place des voix
elle est accusée préférées
l'humour est chez la femme
latendresse
qui aurait tué m c'est pas que je n'y a
ni d
jean gabin
elle est en principe
oh
ptt
qu'elle est
tu as perdu
et que tu voudrais
d'un gabarit
de 36 ans
ce que tu déteste par dessus tout
mes deux fils
comment es tu mourir
quel est à présent de ton esprit
super bien je suis ici avec toi et
davies
vivre et laisser vivre trois remercier
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu